le sous dimensionnement qu'on appelle en
anglais le downsizing c'est une façon de
camoufler une augmentation de prix en
réduisant la quantité de l'emballage
cette pratique est fâcheuse par exemple
quand on veut faire du sucre à la crème
on a besoin 250 millilitres de crème et
que discrètement le fabricant a diminué
la taille du contenant à 237 millilitres
et que dire des amateurs de hot dogs qui
ont eu le même genre de surprise cet été
en achetant des saucisses de marques
hygrade mais poli ou choix du président
les fabricants ont en effet décidé que
pour le même prix les gens mangeront -
en mettant dorénavant que 10,6 dans
l'emballage comme l'épée en dogues se
vendent encore à la douzaine
il vous restera 2.1 extra
la seule façon d'être kifkif c'est
d'acheter 6 dizaines de saucisses et 5
douzaine de pain non mais franchement